There's not much to the story of how Chase got injured. He was invited to a New Year's party in Philadelphia. He flies in, goes to the party, goes back to an apartment where he's staying with three other people, gets up around 7:00 in the morning.
关于Chase如何受伤的故事其实很简单。他受邀去费城参加一个新年派对。他乘飞机抵达，参加了派对，随后回到他与另外三个人合住的公寓，并在早上7点左右起床。
Lack of sleep, still hungover, maybe a little drunk from the night before. And I went to the bathroom, and I tripped. And next thing I know, I'm on the ground. All three of them are around me. They're freaking out.
睡眠不足，还有宿醉，或许还有前一天晚上留下的醉意。我去洗手间时绊倒了。下一刻我发现自己躺在地上。他们三个人都围着我，被吓坏了。
He's concussed, doesn't know where he is or what's happening. They're like, get up.
他脑震荡了，不知道自己在哪里，也不知道发生了什么。他们说，快起来。
And I was so confused. I was like, OK, I'm trying. And I was just like face down on the ground. My arm was like this, and I was pushing.
我当时非常困惑。我说，好，我正在试。我当时就是脸朝下趴在地上。我的手臂是这样摆放的，我在用力撑。
And they were shaking-- the moment I realized I was paralyzed was they were shaking my leg. And I kind of knew something was happening to my leg. I was like, are you touching me? And they're like, yeah, we're shaking your leg. You don't feel that? And I was like, no.
他们当时在摇晃——我意识到自己瘫痪的那一刻，就是他们摇晃我腿的时候。我隐约感觉到我的腿出事了。我说，你们在碰我吗？他们说，对啊，我们在摇你的腿。你感觉不到吗？我说，没有。
At the hospital, he learns that there's trauma and internal bleeding in his spinal cord around the C4 vertebra. They tell him he may never walk again. He can't stand, or control his arms, or use his hands. It's not clear he ever will.
在医院里，他得知脊髓C4椎骨附近有创伤和内出血。他们告诉他，他可能永远无法再走路了。他无法站立，无法控制双臂，也无法使用双手。目前还不清楚他是否能够康复。
Somebody has to feed him. He's all alone, no visitors. He's basically immobile in front of a television that's set to Comedy Central, which those particular weeks, he says, was reruns of The Office most of the day. He said he watched from season one all the way up through the finale of season nine, and then season one began again.
有人得负责喂他吃饭。他孑然一身，没有访客。他基本上瘫在电视机前，频道锁定在喜剧中心，据他说，那几个星期里，电视上大部分时间都在重播《办公室》。他说他从第一季一直看到第九季大结局，然后又重新开始看第一季。
And one day early in the ICU, he's in a group chat with his buddies-- which means, since he can't pick up his phone, a nurse reads to him what they are saying, and then he dictates what to write back. And they're trying to cheer him up. And they come up with a project for him, a goal, a heroic goal, an unusual goal, a goal that is the reason that I wanted to talk to Chase, this goal that really started as a joke.
后来有一天在ICU时，他加入了一个好友群聊——这意味着，由于他拿不起手机，护士会替他读出他们的消息，然后他口述回复内容。他们正试图让他振作起来。他们为他想了一个项目，一个目标，一个英雄般的目标，一个不同寻常的目标——这个目标正是我想采访Chase的原因，这个目标最初其实只是个玩笑。
My one friend Julian said, get better. Dan said he'd let you kick him in the [BLEEP] when you get home.
我的一个朋友Julian说，祝你早日康复。Dan说等你回家，他就让你踢他的蛋蛋。
Oh, wait a second. Let me just stop the story right there. I actually checked with our lawyers. It's not actually forbidden to say that word on the radio in the United States, but it falls into a gray area. And rather than beep it over and over as you tell the story, we thought we might just substitute a word when you and I are talking. And here are the phrases our lawyers approved to replace that word with-- manliness, man parts, nether region, loins, twins.
噢，等一下。让我在这里先暂停一下故事。我其实咨询过我们的律师了。在美国，在广播里说那个词其实并不违规，但它处于灰色地带。比起在你讲述故事时不断地消音，我们觉得不如在你我交谈时用一个词来代替它。以下是我们的律师批准的替代词——男子气概、男人的部位、下体、私处、双胞胎。
[LAUGHS] Sorry. That is so-- what was the first one?
[笑] 抱歉。这太……第一个词是什么来着？
Manliness, man parts, nether region, loins, twins.
男子气概、男人的部位、下体、私处、双胞胎。
You can't say [BLEEP]?
你不能说那个词吗？
Can't say [BLEEP]. Can't say [BLEEP]. We specifically asked about [BLEEP] and [BLEEP].
不能说那个词。不能说那个词。我们专门问过关于那两个词的事。
[LAUGHS] Sorry. This is such a funny part of this conversation. Well, what do you think is best? I'll just go with whatever you prefer.
[笑] 抱歉。这段对话真是太搞笑了。嗯，你觉得哪个最好？我随你喜欢就行。
I like nether region just because it sounds the funniest to me.
我喜欢“下体”，因为它听起来最有趣。
OK, we can do that. I like it, the nethers.
好的，就这么办。我喜欢这个词，“下体”。
The nethers. Before long, Chase got physical therapy, where they planned what kind of electric wheelchair they would get him because there was a chance his arms and legs would never recover. But of course, he knew exactly where he was headed, a goal so pure that even a small child could understand it, a goal set specifically because his friends believed he never could reach it.
“下体”。没过多久，Chase开始了物理治疗，他们当时在计划为他准备什么样的电动轮椅，因为他的双臂和双腿有可能永远无法恢复。但当然，他很清楚自己的目标，这个目标是如此纯粹，连小孩子都能理解，这个目标之所以被设定，是因为他的朋友们相信他永远无法实现它。
Dan would let me kick him in the nethers. I kept that in the back of my head the entire time. The entire time I was getting better, I was like, Dan's going to have it. Dan's going to have it.
Dan会让我踢他的下体。我一直把这件事记在心里。整个康复期间，我都在想，Dan要遭殃了。Dan要遭殃了。
You had a goal.
你有一个目标。
I had a goal. I had a lot of goals. And on a more serious note, that was-- having multiple goals was so important to the recovery.
我有一个目标。我有很多目标。严肃地说，拥有多个目标对于康复非常重要。
In fact, he had three goals. Kicking Dan in the nethers was the most ambitious and pie in the sky, but the other two were no cakewalk either and also pretty idiosyncratic. Take this next goal.
事实上，他有三个目标。踢Dan的下体是最宏大且遥不可及的，但另外两个目标也绝非易事，而且非常独特。看看下一个目标。
To flip people off, to give the middle finger. And I worked so hard on my hands.
对人竖中指，竖起中指。我为我的手做了大量练习。
How old are you?
你多大了？
25.
25岁。
OK.
好的。
But come on. Come on. I couldn't move my fingers at all until about two and 1/2 weeks in. I had a breakdown with the therapist there. I was crying. It was one of my first big mental breakdowns.
但是拜托。拜托。在受伤大概两周半之前，我的手指一点都动不了。我在治疗师面前崩溃了。我在哭。那是我第一次经历重大的心理崩溃。
He thought he'd never use his fingers again. She's like, let's see, and told him to try to move his thumb. He couldn't do it, but he could move his index finger, like just a quiver, like a millimeter. And he set this goal, which he actually achieved a month and a half later with incredible effort. He was finally able to get his middle finger fully straight.
他以为自己永远无法再用手指了。她试着看看，让他试着动动大拇指。他做不到，但他能动食指，就像抽动一下，移动了一毫米。他设定了这个目标，并在一个半月后付出了难以置信的努力后真正实现了。他终于能够把中指完全伸直了。
And I freaked out. I was like, look, I did it. All the therapists look at me, and I just start flipping all of them off. And they're like, yay, yay!
我简直惊呆了。我说，看，我做到了。所有的治疗师都看着我，我就开始对他们每一个人竖中指。他们说，耶，耶！
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
His next goal-- well, Chase actually lives in California, but he'd flown to Philadelphia for the New Year's party and injured himself in Philadelphia, and was now recovering in Philadelphia. And for him, as an out-of-towner, one of the things that Philadelphia means is those steps Sylvester Stallone runs up in the movie Rocky in front of the Philadelphia Museum of Art. Chase wanted to climb them, all 72 steps.
他的下一个目标——Chase其实住在加州，但他为了新年派对飞到费城，在费城受了伤，现在又在费城康复。对他来说，作为一个外地人，费城的标志性象征就是史泰龙在电影《洛奇》里跑上去的费城艺术博物馆门前的那些台阶。Chase想爬上这些台阶，全程72级。
I told my therapist about it. And even though, in the beginning, she thought it was going to be impossible, we just kept practicing steps as much as we could. That's the thing about the therapy, is they take your goals and they work at it, no matter how ridiculous they are, whether it's kicking someone in the nethers or climbing up some steps. They really try to gear it towards what you want.
我告诉了我的治疗师。尽管起初她认为这不可能实现，但我们还是尽可能多地练习上台阶。这就是治疗的意义所在，他们接受你的目标并为之努力，无论它们看起来多么荒唐，不管是踢某人的下体还是爬台阶。他们确实会根据你想要的东西来调整治疗。
To give you a sense of why the therapist thought it would be impossible or ridiculous-- when Chase came up with this goal, he couldn't stand. He couldn't walk. Later, they would suspend him above a treadmill with ropes, and two therapists would move his legs to get the muscles to remember what walking is. Then he would learn to walk with a cane and then without a cane. But before he did any of that, back when he was still just learning to get around in a wheelchair, they started him going upstairs to make this goal. And two and 1/2 months after he entered the hospital, he went to the steps where Rocky trained, rode in a wheelchair up to the first step, stood, and started climbing slowly, watching each foot as he planted it-- one, then the other, a physical therapist steadying him from behind.
为了让你了解为什么治疗师认为这不可能或很荒唐——当Chase提出这个目标时，他无法站立。他无法走路。后来，他们会用绳子把他悬挂在跑步机上方，两名治疗师会移动他的双腿，让肌肉记住走路的感觉。然后他学习用拐杖走路，最后不用拐杖。但在那之前，当他还在练习坐轮椅时，他们就开始让他练习上楼梯以实现这个目标。在他住院两个半月后，他来到了洛奇训练的地方，坐轮椅来到第一级台阶前，站起来，缓慢地开始向上攀爬，盯着每一个落脚点——迈出这一步，再迈出下一步，一名物理治疗师在身后稳住他。
And balance is difficult. I have to look down. So the whole time I'm looking down at my legs. And I can hear a bunch of people clapping, but I'm so focused. I go up the first little flight, go up the second little flight. I look up-- hundreds of people.
平衡很难。我必须向下看。所以整个过程我都在看我的双腿。我能听到很多人在鼓掌，但我非常专注。我走完第一小段台阶，又走完第二小段。我抬头一看——数百人。
Nice.
真棒。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
He actually posted a thing online saying he was going to climb the Rocky steps and livestream it, and he didn't expect that lots of people would actually show up in person to see him climb to the top.
他实际上在网上发帖说他要去爬洛奇台阶并进行直播，但他没想到会有那么多人亲自到场看他爬到顶端。
Almost there. One more! One more! One more!
快到了。再一级！再一级！再一级！
[CHEERING AND CLAPPING]
[欢呼和鼓掌声]
So, a triumph. But there was one goal left, the final goal, the most difficult goal for a bunch of reasons that we'll get to in a minute-- kicking Dan in the nethers. Dr. Emily Beus is one of Chase's physical therapists. She says most of her patients had spinal cord injuries, and they had all kinds of goals. But when Chase first told her about this one, she was like, wait, you want to work on your kicking why?
所以，这是一个胜利。但还有一个目标没完成，最终目标，由于我们稍后会提到的原因，这是最难的一个——踢Dan的下体。Emily Beus博士是Chase的物理治疗师之一。她说她的大多数病人都有脊髓损伤，他们有各种各样的目标。但当Chase第一次告诉她这个目标时，她是这样反应的，等等，你为什么要练习踢人？
That was definitely a first for me. I'm not sure I've ever had anybody request that. And as a physical therapist, just like with doctors or anybody else, our general motto is "do no harm."
这对我来说绝对是第一次。我不确定我以前是否遇到过有人提出这种要求。作为物理治疗师，就像医生或其他任何人一样，我们的基本准则是“不伤害”。
Oh, it hadn't occurred to me that you helping him kick Dan in the nethers could actually be a violation of your Hippocratic oath.
哦，我还没想到你帮他踢Dan的下体竟然可能违反你的希波克拉底誓言。
I know. Yeah. Well, it just made me hesitate because we talk about ethics a lot, and we never want to harm anybody else. And so I was a little hesitant at first, but the more we talked about it and I understood that it was not like he was just going to try to go out and harm somebody without their consent.
我知道。是的。嗯，这只是让我犹豫了，因为我们经常谈论伦理，我们从不想伤害任何人。所以起初我有点犹豫，但当我们谈得越多，我就越明白他并不是想在未经对方同意的情况下试图去伤害别人。
Yeah.
没错。
And so I said, OK, well, let's break it down.
所以我说，好的，那我们来把它拆解开来。
We practiced kicking. We warmed up with some kicking a soccer ball because it was soft. It was easy.
我们练习了踢腿。我们先练习踢足球来热身，因为它很软。这很容易。
Kicking a soccer ball-- a lot of kicking isn't just the leg you're kicking with. It's being able to have your balance standing on one leg, which for Chase was a challenge.
踢足球——踢球不仅仅是用那只踢球的脚。它需要你能够单脚站立保持平衡，这对Chase来说是一个挑战。
It's a lot more difficult for me to stand on my right leg, even today.
直到今天，对我来说用右脚站立保持平衡还是更难一些。
And then it was a little bit higher kicks to a standing-up kind of bolster. And we practiced each leg and figured out which leg would produce the most force, which one he had the best balance on, and all of that.
然后我们练习了对着站立的垫子踢更高。我们练习了两条腿，找出哪条腿产生的力量最大，哪条腿的平衡感最好，等等。
The left side of my body is in better condition, so we thought, is it better to balance on my left leg and kick with the right? Turned out no, it was better to just try to balance on my right and kick with the left because it was a lot stronger.
我身体左侧的状态更好，所以我们就在想，用左脚平衡、用右脚踢是否更好？结果证明不是，最好还是尝试用右脚平衡、用左脚踢，因为左脚强壮得多。
So it was kind of strategic and fun just to sort of figure out which one would get the task done, make it so it wasn't just like he was tapping him or--
所以这是一个战略性且有趣的过程，弄清楚哪一种方式能完成任务，不仅是轻轻踢他一下……
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Which leg would really do some damage.
看看哪条腿真的能造成一些伤害。
Yeah, I mean, which would make him feel like he'd really recovered.
没错，我是说，哪条腿能让他感觉自己真正康复了。
Chase did recover much more quickly and completely than most of the patients Emily saw, she says. His particular injury just ended up working out like that. And so just a month after the Rocky steps, he reached his final goal and made a little video.
Chase的恢复速度和程度确实比Emily看到的多数病人要快得多，也彻底得多，她说。他的伤情最终就是这样康复的。所以，在爬完洛奇台阶一个月后，他实现了最终目标，并拍了一个小视频。
Hey, guys. I'm Dan. I'm about to be kicked in the [BLEEP].
嘿，伙计们。我是Dan。我马上就要被踢那个[下体]了。
In the video, Dan seems like the most good-natured person who has ever lived. He smiles.
视频里，Dan看起来是有史以来脾气最好的人。他在笑。
And let me tell you, when the day did come, when we were actually doing it, the first time I went for the kick I thought I got him, but I hit him in the thigh and not the nethers. And he could have faked it. He could have laid on the floor and pretended to be in pain. Immediately, he was like, Chase, you missed. Do it again. I'm like, all right, here we go.
让我告诉你，当那一天真正到来，我们真的要开始的时候，我第一次尝试踢的时候以为踢中了，但我踢到了他的大腿，而不是下体。他本可以假装的。他可以躺在地上假装很痛苦。他立刻说，Chase，你没踢中。再来一次。我说，好吧，我们开始吧。
In the video, Dan stands there, legs spread awkwardly, one hand covering his eyes, but laughing, which I think summarizes all the feelings you could have in that moment. Chase quietly says sorry. He told me he felt bad for Dan, but he also felt like he'd come so far.
视频里，Dan站在那里，双腿尴尬地叉开，一只手遮着眼睛，但在笑，我觉得这总结了那一刻的所有感受。Chase小声说对不起。他告诉我他为Dan感到难过，但也觉得他已经走了很长一段路。
When the text got sent initially, they thought it was never going to happen. They thought it was going to be impossible. Instead, I slammed him in his nethers. I slammed him, Ira.
当那条短信最初发送时，他们以为这永远不会发生。他们以为这不可能。相反，我狠狠踢了他的下体。我狠狠踢了他，Ira。
Oh!
噢！
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
He was on the ground. He was not OK. He was OK after. And also, he says in the video, "Chase slammed me in the nethers, and it felt so good." Because he, at the same time, was so proud of me for being able to get to a point where that was even possible.
他当时倒在地上。他当时并不好受。但之后他没事了。而且，他在视频里说，“Chase狠狠踢了我的下体，感觉真好。”因为他同时为我感到骄傲，为我能达到那一刻所展现的可能性感到高兴。
He still has a way to go. He's not all recovered, still devoting his days to physical therapy. His latest goal says a lot about where he is right now. He wants to walk well enough that people can't tell he ever had an injury. He wants to seem how he used to be.
他还有很长的路要走。他没有完全康复，仍然每天投入物理治疗。他最近的目标说明了他目前的处境。他希望能够走得足够好，让人看不出他曾经受过伤。他希望看起来像以前一样。
It's still hard for him to open a water bottle or change a light bulb. Chest down, he doesn't feel temperature at all. So he can feel the water from the shower hit him, but can't tell how hot it is.
对他来说，打开水瓶或更换灯泡依然困难。胸部以下，他完全感觉不到温度。所以他能感觉到淋浴的水打在身上，但不知道水有多烫。
And then my fingers, I can feel when they're touching things, but I can't always feel the texture. So when I'm reaching for something in my pocket, I don't always know if I'm grabbing my wallet, or my keys, or just the pants. It's kind of difficult. But I do have sensation everywhere. It just varies, the level.
还有我的手指，我能感觉到它们在触碰东西，但我不能总是感觉到质地。所以当我在口袋里摸东西时，我不总是知道我抓到的是钱包、钥匙，还是仅仅是裤子。这有点困难。但我确实到处都有知觉。只是程度不同而已。
But it's interesting that you are so recovered, but you're not totally there. You've come so far, but you're not totally there. You're in this weird limbo.
但有趣的是，你康复得这么多，却又没有完全康复。你走过了漫长的路，却还没有完全到达终点。你处于这种奇怪的边缘状态。
It is weird. I'm not sure how much I like it. I just want all this to be done. I just want the recovery to be done. Whether I fully recover or not, I just want to be at the point where I don't have to dedicate my entire life to getting better.
这确实很奇怪。我不确定我有多喜欢这种状态。我只想要这一切结束。我只想要康复过程结束。无论我是否完全康复，我只想达到那种不需要把整个生命都投入到改善身体状况的程度。
The point I'm super excited to get to is when I'm not thinking about it. Because right now, every time I move my hand, it's just in my head-- oh, I have this injury. Every time I move my leg, oh, I have this injury.
我非常渴望达到那种不用再去想这件事的状态。因为现在，每次我动我的手，我的脑子里就只是——噢，我有这个伤。每次我动我的腿，噢，我有这个伤。
He wants to get to the point where he's used to what his body can do at whatever level that turns out to be. He doesn't want this dominating his thoughts and his whole day. But this is the thing-- recovery means something different for everybody. Each person sets their own goals. Part of recovering is actually defining for yourself what your own recovery means.
他想达到那种他习惯于身体所能做的一切的状态，无论那种程度最终是什么水平。他不希望这件事支配他的想法和整天的时间。但这就是重点——康复对每个人来说意义都不同。每个人设定自己的目标。康复的一部分实际上是为你自己定义你的康复意味着什么。
Today on our program, we have people coming back from some very different things. They're in the same limbo Chase is in, where they're partly there, but not all the way. They're in the middle, which is this moment of enormous hope, but also a lot of other stuff too. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天在我们的节目中，我们邀请了那些从不同境遇中走出来的人。他们和Chase处于同样的边缘状态，他们部分达到了目标，但没有完全达到。他们处于中间地带，这是一个充满巨大希望的时刻，但也包含了很多其他东西。我是WBEZ芝加哥的Ira Glass，这里是《美国生活》。请继续收听。
Act One, Naked Lunch. So today's show really came out of a question that one of our longtime producers, Susan Burton, had about something that's happening in her own life. You may remember, a few months ago, Susan told a story on our show about her eating disorder. And that was something she had kept secret for most of her life from everyone in her life, and then she revealed the secret in a book she wrote, this memoir that came out last summer.
第一幕，裸露的午餐。今天的节目源于我们长期制作人Susan Burton在自己生活中遇到的一个问题。你可能还记得，几个月前，Susan在我们的节目中讲述了她患有饮食失调的故事。那是她一生中对所有人都隐瞒的秘密，直到她在去年夏天出版的一本回忆录中揭露了这个秘密。
And the book is about what it's like to have an eating disorder, not about how to get over one. Because when Susan wrote it, she was not over it. She still isn't. And over the two and 1/2 years that she's been working toward recovery, she started to wonder, what does recovery from an eating disorder even mean? A heads-up that if hearing stories about eating disorders aggravates your own eating disorder symptoms, this may affect you. Here's Susan.
这本书讲述了患有饮食失调是什么感觉，而不是关于如何克服它。因为当Susan写这本书时，她还没有克服它。她现在仍然没有完全克服。在过去两年半致力于康复的过程中，她开始好奇，从饮食失调中康复究竟意味着什么？提醒一下，如果听到关于饮食失调的故事会引发你自己的症状，请注意，这可能会对你产生影响。下面有请Susan。
At the beginning of recovery, I never thought about recovery. What I thought about was telling my secret. The secret was the eating disorder I'd had for 30 years.
在康复之初，我从没想过康复。我想的是如何倾诉我的秘密。这个秘密就是我患了30年的饮食失调。
What was this eating disorder? It had been so many things-- starving, bingeing. It's not like you pick an eating disorder as a teenage girl and you have that one for the rest of your life. The [BLEEP] up relationship with food is what you have for the rest of your life-- or what it felt like, to me, I was going to have when, at age 45, I stepped into my therapist's office for the first time.
这种饮食失调是什么？它表现为多种形式——节食、暴饮暴食。并不是说你作为一个少女会选择一种饮食失调，然后余生就一直带着它。你余生所面对的是与食物那种糟糕的关系——或者对我而言，当我45岁第一次走进治疗师办公室时，我觉得我余生都将背负这种关系。
I'm preoccupied with food, and I don't want to be, I told her. That was the beginning. Now I'm in the middle, two and 1/2 years in. And what that looks like, it isn't easy to summarize. Easy would be, I now do X behavior instead of Y. I don't have that kind of sentence, but I do have examples like this one.
我告诉她，我被食物所占据，我不想这样。那是开始。现在我处于中间阶段，已经过去两年半了。它看起来是什么样，并不容易概括。容易的说法是，我现在做X行为而不是Y行为。我没有那样的结论，但我确实有一些像这样的例子。
One afternoon this spring, my husband made cookies. I took one from the cooling rack, and I ate it with him and our 16-year-old son. Maybe that sounds like a small thing. Maybe that sounds like nothing. I have to curb that impulse to tell you how small these things are, how nothing they are, because with an eating disorder how you relate to food connects to and disrupts how you relate to everyone in your life.
今年春天的一个下午，我丈夫做了饼干。我从冷却架上拿了一块，和丈夫还有我们16岁的儿子一起吃了。也许这听起来是件小事。也许这听起来什么都不是。我必须克制住想告诉你们这些事情有多小、多无足轻重的冲动，因为在饮食失调中，你与食物的关系会连接并破坏你与生活中每个人的关系。
And eating something sweet at that time of day-- for me, that's not nothing. That happens alone, in secret, because the pleasure is so intense. It cannot be seen. It cannot be shared. There will be no pleasure if it's shared.
在那一天的那个时候吃点甜食——对我来说，那并不是无足轻重的。那通常是独自秘密进行的，因为那种快感太强烈了。它不能被看见。它不能被分享。如果分享了，就不会有那种快感。
But that day, I leaned against the counter and ate the cookie, and it felt good. It was one of so many things I didn't realize about recovery. It's not just eating intuitively. It's making food something shared instead of something secret.
但那天，我靠在柜台上吃了那块饼干，感觉很好。这是我对康复所不知道的许多事情之一。这不仅仅是直觉性饮食。这还包括让食物变成一种分享的东西，而不是秘密的东西。
Another day, my other son, age 13, came into the kitchen. He wanted me to come out to the garden so he could show me how the vines of his cucumbers were hardening as they twined. He wanted to show me now, and it couldn't be now. How could anyone be asking me to do anything now? I couldn't. No. In a second. And he went back outside.
有一天，我另一个13岁的儿子走进厨房。他想让我去花园，这样他可以向我展示他的黄瓜藤在缠绕时是如何变硬的。他现在就想让我去看，但我无法在现在。怎么会有人在这个时候要求我做任何事情？我不行。不行。等一秒钟。然后他回到外面去了。
But the reason I couldn't was that I just pitted cherries that I was going to put on ice cream. The food was incoming, on the way. It could not be stopped. I could not be intruded on.
但我之所以不行是因为我刚刚给要放在冰淇淋上的樱桃去核。食物正在进来，在路上。它不能被停止。我不能被打扰。
When I finished, I went straight to the garden, and my son showed me the vines. I stood there hating myself, reflecting on how many such moments there have been over the years. I can't right now, not right now. I've done a lot of that, like a lot of mothers. And a lot of it has had to do with work.
当我做完后，我直接去了花园，儿子给我看了藤蔓。我站在那里讨厌自己，反思这些年来有多少这样的时刻。我现在不行，不是现在。我做了很多这样的事，像很多母亲一样。其中很大一部分与工作有关。
But work-- come on, really? There's no shame in that admission. There's all this hand wringing about guilt and work and motherhood, but hard work is the most culturally sanctioned thing in America. Try revealing that you've turned your child away because of food.
但工作——拜托，真的吗？这个承认中没有羞耻感。关于内疚、工作和母职，人们对此忧心忡忡，但在美国，努力工作是被文化最认可的事情。试试看透露你因为食物而拒绝了你的孩子，看看人们怎么看你。
Do you detect anger? Most of us with eating disorders-- volcanically angry. Also most of us-- placid or even fun girl disguised. That's part of recovery too, expressing anger, not hiding.
你能察觉到愤怒吗？我们大多数患有饮食失调的人——内心火山口般愤怒。我们大多数人——伪装成随和甚至有趣的女孩。这也是康复的一部分，表达愤怒，而不是隐藏。
My body-- my body is recovering too. It's changing. My body's like those sponges my children always wanted when they were young and we were in line at the grocery store. The sponges are thin, like sticks of gum, the color of Manila envelopes. When you put them in water, they expand. That's what my body has done. It's like one of those flat sponges that expanded.
我的身体——我的身体也在康复。它在变化。我的身体就像那些孩子们小时候在超市排队时总是想要的海绵一样。海绵很薄，像口香糖条，颜色像牛皮信封。当你把它们放进水里，它们就会膨胀。这就是我的身体所经历的。就像那些膨胀起来的扁平海绵之一。
I told this to my therapist. That's an interesting word, flat, she said. It's the word I mean, I emphasized-- flat, not thin. Yes, she said. And you were flat inside too, emotionally.
我告诉了我的治疗师。她说，这是一个有趣的词，“扁平”。我强调，这是我的意思——扁平，不是瘦。是的，她说。而且你在内心也是扁平的，情感上也是。
And that was true. That's what the eating disorder does to you. That's part of why you have it, so you won't feel. That's maybe the whole point.
那也是真的。饮食失调就是这样对你的。这就是为什么你患有它的一部分原因，这样你就不会感到痛苦。这也许就是全部意义所在。
Clothes-- a blue linen dress with buttons down the front. There came a day in May when it was the right weather for it. I put on the dress, which used to be loose, but no longer was. But the difference was that I didn't want it to be loose.
衣服——一件正面有扣子的蓝色亚麻连衣裙。五月的一天，天气正好适合穿它。我穿上这件曾经宽松但现在不再宽松的裙子。但区别在于，我并不希望它宽松。
In the kitchen, my husband reached for me. He put his hands on my waist, rounded them over my hips. And I wanted it. I wanted to be touched. That was new too.
在厨房里，丈夫向我走来。他把手放在我的腰上，环抱住我的臀部。我想要这种感觉。我渴望被触摸。这也是新鲜事。
But the way I've gained the weight-- OK, so this is mixed. Some of it-- it's not the bingeing I did for years, but there's been a lot of reaching for food all day. I long to eat in an orderly way, like meals on plates at consistent times, but I struggle to do so.
但我增重的方式——好吧，这是混合的。有些——这不是我多年来那种暴饮暴食，但确实是一整天都在伸手找东西吃。我渴望以有序的方式进食，比如在固定的时间把饭菜装在盘子里，但我努力尝试却很难做到。
There's a specific meal that comes to mind when I think about not only where I am in recovery, but what I want from it. I want to be normal about lunch. Want to know the scene I associate with lunch? Our This American Life staff meeting, which happens in person once a week, when there's not a pandemic.
当我想到我不仅处于康复的哪个阶段，以及我想要从中得到什么时，有一个特定的进餐场景浮现在脑海中。我想要在午餐问题上表现正常。想知道我与午餐关联的场景吗？我们《美国生活》的员工会议，这在没有疫情的时候每周举行一次。
Every week, food is ordered in and laid out on a table in takeout containers. I've never once taken the food we order in for this meeting. For years, I've watched people pick up plates and just put food on those plates, and then sit down at the meeting and eat that food while we are talking. Every part of this is a marvel to me. But actually, what happens even before they get to the food, that's probably the most important part, that they stood from their desks and came to get the food, neither hating themselves for already having eaten at the wrong time nor brittle and empty because they've been too scared to put anything in.
每周，食物都会被点好放在桌上的外卖盒里。我从来没有拿过我们为这次会议点的食物。多年来，我看着人们拿起盘子，把食物放进去，然后在开会时坐下来吃那些食物，同时我们还在说话。这其中的每一个部分对我来说都是奇迹。但实际上，甚至在他们去拿食物之前发生的事情，那可能是最重要的部分，他们从办公桌前站起来去拿食物，既不因为已经在错误的时间吃过东西而自我厌恶，也不会因为太害怕不敢吃任何东西而变得脆弱空虚。
I imagine hunger rising in a normal way in their bodies, a kind of rising hunger that's so unfamiliar. It's like I crave it in the way people maybe crave love, or touch, or something. It happens so rarely for me.
我想象着饥饿在他们体内以一种正常的方式升起，这种升起的饥饿感是如此陌生。就像我渴望它，就像人们可能渴望爱、触摸或某种东西一样。这种情况对我来说太少见了。
This is what I'm thinking about when I sit in a circle of coworkers with plates on their laps. I'm looking at these people and imagining what they feel in their bodies. It makes me feel very distant from them in a way that's kind of far reaching, and it extends out to other ways I relate to my coworkers and everyone in my life. So yeah, in recovery, I want to be normal about lunch.
这就是当我坐在同事中间、腿上放着盘子时所想的。我看着这些人，想象着他们身体的感觉。这让我觉得与他们有一种深远的距离感，这种距离感扩展到了我与同事以及生活中所有人相处的其他方式。所以，是的，在康复中，我想要在午餐问题上表现正常。
Normal-- we all know there is no normal, that normal is being phased out. But normal stays in my head when it comes to food. Normal about food-- is that recovery?
正常——我们都知道没有所谓的正常，正常正在被淘汰。但当涉及到食物时，正常一直留在我的脑海里。在食物问题上正常——这就是康复吗？
When my book came out and I was first doing interviews about it, people would ask me, where are you with food now? I would say, I'm working toward recovery, but I felt so uneasy whenever I said this. Felt like I was throwing around a phrase I didn't understand and that my ignorance was clear to everyone who actually knew about eating disorder recovery. I just felt so out of my depth, just so new to this, to every part of it, to the working toward it part, to recovery-- which, just to say, was that the process or the end? Was there an end? What does recovery from an eating disorder even mean?
当我的书出版、我第一次接受采访时，人们会问我，你现在和食物的关系如何？我会说，我正在努力康复，但每当我说出这句话时，我都感到非常不安。感觉就像我在使用一个我不理解的短语，而且我的无知在任何真正了解饮食失调康复的人面前一览无余。我感到非常力不从心，对这一切的每一个部分都很陌生，对那部分“努力向它靠拢”，对康复——顺便说一句，这是过程还是终点？有终点吗？从饮食失调中康复究竟意味着什么？
Square one-- I went looking for the official clinical definition of eating disorder recovery. I wanted this as context, as a baseline, but it turned out there was no baseline. There's no consensus about what recovery means. Most definitions include physical criteria like, are you at a healthy weight, and behavioral like, have you stopped bingeing? But there's also how much you're thinking about food, your ability to express emotions, all the stuff that has nothing to do with eating. This is where the lack of consensus comes in, over what other stuff belongs in the definition.
起点——我去寻找饮食失调康复的官方临床定义。我想要这个作为背景，作为一个基准，但事实证明没有基准。关于康复的含义，没有共识。大多数定义包括身体标准，比如，你的体重是否健康，以及行为标准，比如，你是否停止了暴饮暴食？但也有关于你对食物的思考程度，你表达情绪的能力，所有与饮食无关的东西。这就是缺乏共识的地方，关于还有什么属于这个定义。
Intellectually, I was interested in all of this. But emotionally, what I really wanted was to talk about recovery with people who'd been through it, people further along in it than me. I wanted to talk about what recovery felt like to them, maybe as a way of imagining myself into my own version of it. And I had two people in mind. The first one was someone who'd said a single word to me about recovery that captured how I wanted to feel there, a word that I'd been returning to for months. The word was "sturdy."
理智上，我对所有这些都很感兴趣。但在情感上，我真正想做的是与那些经历过康复的人交谈，那些比我走得更远的人。我想谈谈康复对他们来说是什么感觉，也许可以作为一种想象自己进入自己的康复版本的方式。我脑子里有两个人选。第一个人对我说了关于康复的一个词，抓住了我想要的那种感觉，一个我几个月来一直反复咀嚼的词。这个词是“坚固”。
I'm very happy to be talking to you again.
很高兴再次与你交谈。
OK, good. Me too.
好的，太棒了。我也是。
If you're-- I don't know-- under 30 and you grew up watching Nickelodeon, you probably know who Jennette McCurdy is. She was a star of teen comedies-- iCarly, Sam & Cat. In her early 20s, she quit acting. It was actually part of her eating disorder recovery. And now she has a podcast called Empty Inside. She interviewed me for it last summer, which is when she said that word, "sturdy," that stayed with me ever since.
如果你……不知道……不到30岁，并且看着尼克国际儿童频道长大，你可能知道Jennette McCurdy是谁。她是青少年喜剧片《爱卡莉》和《萨姆和卡特》的明星。20出头时，她退出了演艺圈。这实际上是她饮食失调康复的一部分。现在她有一个名为《Empty Inside》的播客。去年夏天她采访了我，就在那时她说了那个词，“坚固”，从那时起我就一直记着它。
First and most importantly, I felt sturdy enough in my recovery that I could share my story.
首先也是最重要的，我觉得我在康复中足够坚固，可以分享我的故事。
When we spoke, you use this word to describe your recovery. You said you waited to tell your story until you were sturdy. As soon as you said that word, something about it grabbed me. And then when I responded to you, I even repeated the word, kind of trying it out.
我们交谈时，你用这个词来描述你的康复。你说你等到足够坚固才分享你的故事。当你一说出那个词，它就深深抓住了我。当我回应你时，我甚至重复了这个词，算是尝试了一下。
It just shows a lot of self-knowledge too that you waited to a point where you were sturdy. Because, of course, it opens you up to all kinds of stuff.
这也展现了你有很多自我认知，你等到一个坚固的节点才分享。因为，当然，这会让你面对各种各样的事情。
And it stayed with me after the interview. And I think it had so much significance because it described to me both an emotional and a physical place. I had for so long privileged and tried for frailness and fragility, and so the idea of being sturdy was suddenly appealing to me. Like, a sturdy body, but also sturdiness in the way that you could be buffeted by bad [BLEEP], by the hard experiences, come out OK. You could withstand it. You might get blown about, but you wouldn't get broken. You would be OK.
采访后这个词一直留在我的脑海里。我认为它之所以有如此重要的意义，是因为它向我描述了一个情感和身体上的位置。长期以来，我一直推崇并追求虚弱和脆弱，所以“坚固”这个概念突然吸引了我。比如，一个坚固的身体，以及在你可以被糟糕的[词汇消音]、被艰难经历冲击时依然稳健的坚固。你可以承受它。你可能会被吹得东倒西歪，但你不会破碎。你会没事的。
And I think as far as thinking about my recovery, it's been an interesting word to return to because it's not as woo-woo as some other stuff, like phoenix rising or--
我认为，在思考我的康复方面，这是一个很有趣的词，可以回到它，因为它不像其他一些词那样虚无缥缈，比如凤凰涅槃，或者……
the tiger
雌狮
--yeah, you know what I mean?
……是的，你知道我的意思吧？
Yeah.
我只想保持年轻。所以我说，好吧，我该怎么做才能不长乳房？我妈说，嗯，有一种东西叫热量限制。
There's something really real about it. Anyway.
它有一种真实感。无论如何。
Oh my god.
天呐。
OK, so I want to hear what "sturdy" means to you.
好的，所以我想听听“坚固”对你来说意味着什么。
Well, I mean, I just have to say, anytime somebody starts comparing people to animals-- the lioness prowls and the night sky-- I'm like, you lost me. There's nothing real that I can grab onto. So for me, it's really important to use language that reflects reality.
嗯，我的意思是，我不得不说，每当有人开始把人比作动物——雌狮徘徊在夜空下——我就觉得，你失去了我。没有什么是能让我抓住的真实东西。所以对我来说，使用反映现实的语言非常重要。
What "sturdy" meant to Jennette was that she felt strong enough in her recovery to speak publicly about her eating disorder without falling back into it. And to give you a sense of what she had to recover from, her eating disorder started when she was 11.
“坚固”对Jennette来说意味着，她觉得在康复中足够强大，可以公开谈论她的饮食失调，而不必再陷入其中。为了让你了解她必须从中康复的东西，她的饮食失调始于11岁。
And being a child actor, I always played roles that were younger than my actual age. And it was very beneficial to be able to play roles that were younger than my age because you could work longer hours. So they were much more inclined to cast you if you were 12 playing eight than if you were eight playing eight.
作为一个童星，我总是扮演比我实际年龄小的角色。能够扮演比我年龄小的角色非常有益，因为你可以工作更长时间。所以，如果你是12岁演8岁，他们比你8岁演8岁更倾向于选择你。
But when I was 11, I sort of started developing a little, tiny-- I'll call it a nipple bud. I don't know what else to call it, like just a little-- like the littlest peep of a breast. And my mom had actually had cancer when I was two years old, so I thought-- the only thing I knew about lumps in breasts was that that meant cancer. So I thought, oh, no, she had cancer. Now I have cancer.
但当我11岁时，我开始发育了一点点——我会称之为乳芽。我不知道还能怎么称呼它，就像只是稍微一点点——就像胸部冒出一点点痕迹。我妈在我两岁时得过癌症，所以我认为——关于乳房肿块，我唯一知道的就是那意味着癌症。所以我想，哦，不，她得过癌症。现在我有癌症了。
I showed my mom this lump. She felt it, and she said, oh, Nettie, no. You don't have cancer. You're just getting breasts.
我给妈妈看了这个肿块。她摸了摸，说，噢，Nettie，不。你没有癌症。你只是在发育乳房。
And in my 11-year-old mind, breasts were just about as bad as cancer, truly. I did not want to be older. I knew that that would be really, really not good for my acting career. And I was largely the financial support for my family. So I knew that meant bad things for my family.
在我11岁的心智中，乳房和癌症几乎一样糟糕，真的。我不想长大。我知道这对我的演艺事业非常非常不利。我基本上是家庭的经济支柱。所以我知道这意味着对我的家庭来说是坏事。
I just wanted to stay young. So I said, well, how can I keep the boobs from coming? And my mom said, well, there's this thing called calorie restriction.
我只是想保持年轻。所以我问，怎样才能让胸部不发育？我妈说，有一种方法叫热量限制。
Jennette actually wrote a song about this conversation. It's from a one-woman show she's been performing.
Jennette实际上为这次对话写了一首歌。它来自她一直在表演的一场个人秀。
(SINGING) It might be time for me to teach you a thing called calorie restriction, yay.
（演唱）也许是时候教你一种叫热量限制的东西了，耶。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I'm 11 years old. I don't know what that is. Well, 11 years old is the perfect age to find out.
我才11岁。我不知道那是什么。好吧，11岁是发现它的最佳年龄。
And from that point on, she not only coached me, but really-- she had had eating disorders of her own for quite a long time, so we were sort of this-- I call it a mommy and me eating disorder team. And we were just-- we'd help each other out every single night-- meal planning for the next day, calorie counting for the day that we just experienced, and swapping tips and tricks, and reading Woman's World magazine diet pages together. And we were just-- I thought it was this fabulous thing where we were just this little duo. And I thought, wow, I'm so lucky my mom's helping me with this thing. I'm helping her. Look at us go.
从那时起，她不仅辅导我，而且实际上——她自己也患有很长一段时间的饮食失调，所以我们算是……我称之为“母女饮食失调团队”。我们只是……我们每天晚上都会互相帮助——为第二天制定膳食计划，计算我们刚刚经历的一天的热量，交换技巧和窍门，一起阅读《女性世界》杂志的饮食页面。我们只是……我觉得这是一件美妙的事情，我们只是这对小搭档。我想，哇，我太幸运了，我妈妈正在帮我处理这件事。我也在帮她。看看我们。
(SINGING) Life's better when you're empty inside. It's harder when you're full. Trust me, I've tried.
（演唱）当你内心空虚时，生活会更好。当你饱满时，生活会更艰难。相信我，我试过。
The idea of going over the calories for your day with your mother-- I mean, how many times in my life have I made little lists of 200 plus 150 plus-- but it was so alone. I mean, my god, that you were doing it with your mother.
和母亲一起复盘你一天的热量摄入这个想法——我的意思是，我一生中做过多少次200加150加……的清单——但这太孤独了。我的天，你竟然是和母亲一起做的。
Yeah, yeah, absolutely. I mean, I think definitely the experience of eating disorders so often is something that's so lonely. And while it became that for me after my mom died, and the eating disorder switched to bulimia, for almost the entire time that I had anorexia, it was very much a team sport.
是的，是的，绝对是。我的意思是，我认为饮食失调的体验通常是非常孤独的。虽然在我母亲去世后对我来说变成了那样，饮食失调转为暴食症，但在我患厌食症的几乎整个过程中，它更像是一项团队运动。
Now you try, sweetheart.
现在你来试试，亲爱的。
OK, Mommy. (SINGING) Life's better when you're empty inside. I will stay empty to fill you with pride.
好的，妈妈。（演唱）当你内心空虚时，生活会更好。我将保持空虚，以让你充满自豪。
Nice.
好极了。
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和掌声]
Was there, like, a moment or, like, a stage where you started using the word "recovery" to describe your experience to yourself?
有没有那么一个时刻或阶段，你开始使用“康复”这个词来向自己描述你的经历？
Well, I'm glad we talked a little bit about woo-woo words earlier, because there was something, actually, in recovery that I did not like. When I thought of the word "recovery," I thought it's somebody in head-to-toe linen, just beach waves, grinning ear to ear, laughing about how easy their life is, picking up a seashell and tossing it into the sea. That was not how I felt about life or was sure I would ever, ever feel about life.
嗯，我很高兴我们之前稍微谈论了一下那些虚无缥缈的词，因为实际上，在康复中有些东西我不喜欢。当我想到“康复”这个词时，我想到的是一个从头到脚穿着亚麻布的人，带着海滩风格的波浪发，咧着嘴大笑，谈论着她的生活是多么轻松，捡起一个贝壳扔进海里。那不是我对生活的感受，也不确定我是否会以这种方式感受生活。
So I was very wary of using the word "recovery" for quite some time. And I would say I-- I just try to bypass that and use other words. I'm trying to think of what I said. I would just be-- I would say it's something I'm working on.
所以很长一段时间里，我对使用“康复”这个词非常谨慎。我会说我……我只是试着绕过它，使用其他的词。我想想我说了什么。我会说这是我正在努力的事情。
Midway through, she got to a point that sounds a lot like where I am now. She describes the feeling this way.
在半路中，她达到了一个听起来很像我现在处境的阶段。她这样描述那种感觉。
I've been in recovery for a few years, and I'm not where I want to be. This has been very stop and go. It's been a very good week, bad week. I'm not satisfied with that. I want to wake up tomorrow and work toward being fully recovered. I think it's time, and I felt ready.
我康复已经几年了，但我还没达到我想要的地步。这断断续续的。有过非常好的一周，也有过糟糕的一周。我不满足于此。我想明天醒来，努力达到完全康复。我认为是时候了，我感觉准备好了。
Yeah. So at that point, I mean, because-- among the reasons I wanted to talk to you is because you are-- as somebody who dislikes the phrase "recovery journey" as much as you-- but you are further along that beach-- along the beach in your linen dress than I am. And I feel really ready to be on the other side of this. So for somebody like me who's listening to you tell this story and is like, I have that thought too, I want to put it behind me, so like how are you able-- what did you do next that got you to where you are now?
是的。所以在那一点上，我的意思是，因为……我想要和你交谈的原因之一是因为你……作为一个和你一样讨厌“康复旅程”这个短语的人——但你确实比我在沙滩上穿着亚麻裙走得更远。我真的准备好跨过这一关了。所以对于像我这样听你讲故事并想说，我也有那个想法，我想把它抛在脑后的人，你是怎么做到的？你接下来做了什么让你走到了现在的位置？
Jeanette's answer to my question about what she did next was essentially it wasn't what she did next that mattered. It was all the work she'd already done. In therapy, she'd grappled with a lot of the underlying reasons for her eating disorder, felt rage toward her mother, grieved her mother. Yes, she was still purging and still restricting, but way, way less. She just knew that she didn't need those behaviors as coping strategies anymore.
Jeanette对我关于接下来该做什么的问题的回答本质上是，她接下来做什么并不重要。重要的是她已经完成的所有工作。在治疗中，她处理了导致她饮食失调的许多潜在原因，对母亲感到愤怒，哀悼母亲。是的，她仍然有催吐和限制进食，但次数少得多了。她只是知道她不再需要这些行为作为应对策略。
She developed others. She started writing, finding her own voice. That was a few years ago. She describes where she is now as recovered.
她发展了其他策略。她开始写作，找到自己的声音。那是几年前的事了。她将自己目前的状态描述为已康复。
How does the reality of feeling recovered-- how does it compare with what you imagined?
现实中感到康复——它与你想象的相比如何？
Oh my god. It feels like there's not that weight constantly. And while I would say I'm definitely a far distance from peace-- it's another one of the woo-woo words for me-- but I feel good. I feel--
天呐。感觉不再有那种持续的负担。虽然我会说我离平静——这是另一个对我来说虚无缥缈的词——还很遥远，但我感觉很好。我感觉……
She feels more present, more able to focus, more able to feel her feelings and to tolerate the uncomfortable ones. These are all things I hope for, like, precisely. I asked her about something that might sound weird if you've never had an eating disorder, but I feel food in my body just intensely. Jennette said she understood 1,000% what I meant by this. And she said that's gone now too.
她感觉更专注，更能够集中精神，更能够感受自己的情绪并容忍那些不舒服的情绪。这些都是我 precisely（精准）希望得到的。我问她关于一件事，如果你从来没有患过饮食失调，这听起来可能很奇怪，但我强烈地在身体里感受到食物。Jennette说她百分之千理解我所说的意思。她说那种感觉现在也消失了。
It's like I'm more in tune with my body--
就像我与身体更协调了——
Yeah.
是的。
--but less aware of those types of things.
——但对那种类型的感知却少了。
Talking to Jennette, it made me think of a term I'd come across in the research I'd done about the definition of recovery-- indistinguishable, as in a person can recover so fully from an eating disorder that they become indistinguishable from someone who's never had one. It sounded almost sci-fi, like we erase your eating disorder, but also your old identity-- not even something I would want, but also something I instantly wanted. I thought I'd try out "indistinguishable" on Jennette, see if it resonated.
与Jennette交谈让我想到我在研究康复定义时偶然发现的一个术语——“无法区分”，即一个人可以从饮食失调中完全康复，以至于他们与从未患过病的人无法区分。这听起来几乎像是科幻小说，就像我们抹去了你的饮食失调，但也抹去了你的旧身份——这甚至不是我想要的，但也是我立刻想要的东西。我想在Jennette身上试试“无法区分”这个词，看看它是否能产生共鸣。
There's no difference from them and somebody who's never had an eating disorder. Their brain is indistinguishable--
他们与从未患过饮食失调的人没有区别。他们的大脑是无法区分的——
I love that. I love that.
我喜欢那个。我喜欢那个。
But so does that-- so it sounds like that is appealing to you. Is that what you feel like? Do you feel indistinguishable from somebody who's never had an eating disorder?
但所以这……这听起来很吸引你。这就是你的感觉吗？你觉得你和从未患过饮食失调的人无法区分吗？
That's hugely appealing. I think I'd be lying if I said there wasn't always some awareness of that being my past. But I would say that I definitely notice when somebody doesn't have any sort of eating disorder. I feel like I can spot them quite easily like, oh, wow, they just are normal is my thought.
这非常有吸引力。如果我说我对自己那段过去没有意识，那我就在撒谎。但我会说，我确实注意到了当某人没有任何饮食失调时。我觉得我很容易就能看出来，比如，噢，哇，他们就是很正常，我的想法是这样的。
And I would say I'm as close to that as I can possibly be. I have zero food rules. I eat whatever I want-- breakfast, lunch, dinner, snacks-- and I don't think at all about it. It's almost odd to me when I think about my past. I've said several times to my partner-- I'll say, I cannot believe that there was a time in my life when that was who I was.
我会说我已经尽可能接近那种状态了。我没有任何饮食规则。我想吃什么就吃什么——早餐、午餐、晚餐、零食——我一点都不去想它。当我想起我的过去时，这对我来说几乎是很奇怪的。我已经好几次对我的伴侣说了——我会说，我简直不敢相信我生命中曾有过那样的时期。
Yeah.
是的。
It's so wild to me. It feels like a different person. It feels like-- I mean, it does feel like my brain was wired differently then.
这对我来说太疯狂了。感觉就像另一个人。感觉就像——我的意思是，确实感觉那时我的大脑连接方式不同。
I felt hopeful after talking to Jennette, like the freedom she feels, that it was possible for me. Here was someone who'd thought thoughts like mine, who'd felt feelings in her body like mine, who now had new thoughts and a new experience of her body. But I've had these thoughts and feelings for a lot longer time. I'm 47. Jennette just turned 29.
和Jennette交谈后，我感到充满希望，就像她感受到的那种自由，我觉得对我来说也是可能的。这里有一个曾经有过像我一样想法、身体有过像我一样感受的人，她现在有了新的想法和对身体的新体验。但我有这些想法和感受的时间要长得多。我47岁了。Jennette刚满29岁。
One of the realities of my recovery is just that I've lived with an eating disorder for so many years. And I really wanted to talk to someone my own age who'd started recovery in middle age, talk about what it had been like for them. I had someone in mind-- Anissa Gray.
我康复的现实之一仅仅是我患有饮食失调已经很多年了。我真的很想和某个我这个年纪、在中年开始康复的人交谈，谈谈这对他们来说是什么样的。我脑子里有一个人选——Anissa Gray。
Anissa wrote a novel called The Care and Feeding of Ravenously Hungry Girls, which I read last summer and was really affected by. The novel's protagonist is a Black lesbian in her 40s with an eating disorder, a description that explodes all kinds of stereotypes about who has eating disorders and who gets to tell stories about them. Anissa is in her 50s. Her bingeing and purging started in college. Like me, she hid her eating disorder from everyone in her life for years.
Anissa写了一本名为《饥饿女孩的照顾与喂养》的小说，我去年夏天读过，深受触动。小说的主角是一位40多岁的黑人女同性恋，患有饮食失调，这个描述打破了关于谁会患饮食失调以及谁能讲述这些故事的各种刻板印象。Anissa 50多岁了。她的暴饮暴食和催吐始于大学。像我一样，她多年来对生活中的每个人都隐藏了自己的饮食失调。
I used to be very careful about not doing certain behaviors at home when someone could hear. But my wife heard me in the bathroom at one point, and that was when the shoe dropped.
我过去非常小心，在家时如果有人能听见就不做某些行为。但我妻子有一次在洗手间听到了，那就是真相大白的时候。
Anissa agreed to get help, but only because her wife wanted her to. They live outside Atlanta. Anissa found an eating disorder center there. She showed up for her first group therapy session straight from a three-hour workout and a binge and purge.
Anissa同意寻求帮助，但只是因为她妻子希望她这样做。他们住在亚特兰大郊外。Anissa在那里找到了一家饮食失调中心。她第一次参加团体治疗时，刚结束三个小时的锻炼，且刚刚暴饮暴食并催吐完。
And one of the things I noticed immediately upon walking in was that, A, I was the only Black person in the room. I'm not unfamiliar with that scenario. That's essentially been the case for me most, if not all, of my life. So that was fine. But I was really struck by how young the women were in the group.
我走进房间时立刻注意到的事情之一是，A，我是房间里唯一的黑人。我对这种情况并不陌生。这基本上是我一生中大部分时间（如果不是全部时间）的情况。所以那还好。但我真的被组里女性的年轻程度震撼了。
Mostly college age and 20s, one around 40 like Anissa was then. They were the oldest ones.
大多数是大学年龄和20多岁，有一个像Anissa当时一样40岁左右。她们是年纪最大的。
So for those of us who have had this history of eating disorders that's lasted for decades instead of for several years, it's different. The neural pathways are just so much-- the grooves are so much deeper at this age.
所以，对于我们这些饮食失调史持续了几十年而不是几年的群体来说，情况是不同的。神经通路就是如此……在这个年龄段，痕迹太深了。
Yeah, yeah.
是的，是的。
I think back to some adolescent diary entries I would be scrawling after a binge. And this has been a part of my life for two years. I've lost two years to this. And my god, I didn't know how many more years. Is this something you've thought about?
我回想起一些在暴饮暴食后潦草记录的青少年日记。这已经是我生活的一部分两年了。我为此浪费了两年时间。我的天，我不知道还有多少年。这是你想过的事情吗？
Yeah. And I think there's something for women sort of in our cohort perhaps not to have sought treatment early. And that's why I think it's so important for older women to talk about it. When I was out on tour, I met so many women-- 40s, and 50s, and 60s-- who had struggled for just years and years and were finally trying to get well.
是的。我认为我们的群体中，女性在早期寻求治疗的情况也许不多。这就是为什么我认为老年女性谈论它非常重要。我巡回演出时，遇到了很多女性——40多岁、50多岁和60多岁——她们已经挣扎了多年，终于在努力恢复健康。
Yeah. I mean, same. Whenever I get a note from a woman-- 40s, 50s, 60s, even 70s-- it's always somebody who struggled for years. And I have thought the exact same thing as you, that there's something about our contemporaries where we didn't seek treatment early. And then part of me started wondering, is it some kind of Gen X latchkey kid thing--
是的。我的意思是，我也是。每当我收到一个40多岁、50多岁、60多岁甚至70多岁的女性的纸条时，总是有人已经挣扎多年了。我也和你想的一模一样，我们的同龄人似乎有什么东西导致我们没有尽早寻求治疗。然后我开始好奇，这是否是某种X世代“钥匙扣一代”的事情……
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
--or was it just a different time?
……还是仅仅因为是不同的时代？
I didn't know anything about Anissa's own recovery beyond that she had more of it under her belt than I do. 10 years into it, she doesn't feel totally free. It wasn't what she expected at the beginning.
除了她比我多了一些康复经验外，我并不了解Anissa本人的康复过程。十年过去了，她并没有感到完全自由。这并不是她在开始时所期待的。
I thought that there would be an end, that I would reach this place where I didn't have these thoughts anymore, I did not have these urges anymore, and I would be, quote unquote, "normal." I would have a very healthy relationship with food. I have a better relationship with food for sure, but I don't know if I will ever be, quote unquote, "normal" when it comes to food and exercise.
我以为会有一个终点，我会达到一个不再有这些想法、不再有这些冲动的地方，我会变得“正常”。我会和食物有一个非常健康的关系。我确实和食物有了更好的关系，但我不知道我是否会在食物和锻炼问题上永远“正常”。
Yeah.
是的。
I mean, there was disappointment in realizing, OK, this is going to be with me. But there's also a sense of accomplishment and resilience that I have. I know what life used to be like for me, and I know what it is now. So it's easier, but I just have to be vigilant and careful.
我的意思是，意识到“好吧，这会一直伴随着我”确实令人失望。但我也有了一种成就感和韧性。我知道我过去的生活是什么样的，我知道现在是什么样的。所以这更容易了，但我只是必须保持警惕和小心。
So if at the beginning of treatment you're imagining that there will be an end and you'll reach a place where you don't have the thoughts anymore, and then there's kind of a stage where you're disappointed to realize, OK, this is going to be with me-- I'm curious about this as someone who wonders if this will be where I wind up too. And so I'm wondering something that might be hard to answer, but I'm just wondering how you knew that and when you knew that.
所以如果你在治疗开始时想象会有一个终点，你会达到一个不再有那些想法的地方，然后有一个阶段你会失望地意识到，好吧，这会伴随着我——作为一个想知道我是否也会这样的人，我对这件事很好奇。所以我很好奇一个可能很难回答的问题，但我想知道你是如何知道的，以及你是什么时候知道的。
I think it was somewhat evolutionary. I ended treatment with still some of the thoughts, and I was much better at managing them. But as time went on I did start to wonder, OK, so is this just how I'm going to be? I thought it would sort of work itself out as I went on.
我认为它是进化性的。我结束治疗时仍然有一些想法，我只是更善于管理它们了。但随着时间的推移，我确实开始好奇，好吧，那么这就是我以后一直的样子吗？我以为随着时间推移它会自行解决。
And so far it hasn't. On the positive side, the thoughts are much fewer. The compulsions are nothing compared to the way I started out.
到目前为止还没解决。从积极的一面来看，想法少了很多。强迫症比起我刚开始时简直微不足道。
Anissa says that one thing that was important to her in this process was watching a friend get sober. In sobriety, for many people, the idea is that you're never recovered, always in recovery. It's a process that's always ongoing, that never ends, as Anissa saw with her friend.
Anissa说，在这个过程中对她很重要的一件事是看着一个朋友清醒。在清醒的过程中，对许多人来说，观念是你永远不会“康复”，总是处于“康复中”。这是一个持续的过程，永无止境，就像Anissa在她朋友身上看到的那样。
I think it was through that and sort of watching her manage and watching her understand that this is going to be-- this is an ongoing thing for me. Her peace with that, I think, was really helpful for me to sort of get some peace with myself, to not feel so tortured about it, to not feel like, oh, woe is me. This is the cross I have to bear. You can live life, and you can be happy. You just have your thing. Maybe there is some point where I'll just be fine, but I don't see-- but I'm also OK with that.
我想是通过那个过程，看着她管理并理解这一点——这是一件持续的事情。我想她对此的平静对我来说非常有帮助，让我对自己获得了一些平静，不再感到那么折磨，不再感到像“噢，我太可怜了”。这是我必须背负的十字架。你可以生活，你可以快乐。你只是有你的这件事。也许有一天我会完全好起来，但我不确定……而且我也能接受这一点。
Talking to Anissa about being OK with an ongoing thing, it helped me imagine how I might feel in the future. What I want, it's simple. Like if my son were to come into the kitchen and ask me to come to the garden while I was making food, I'd have a reaction like, oh, I'm about to eat something, but I'll come out when I'm through. Do you want to sit with me while I eat, and then we can go out together?
和Anissa谈论接受这种持续的状态，帮助我想象未来可能会是什么感觉。我想要的东西很简单。如果我的儿子走进厨房，在我做饭时要求我去花园，我会有一种反应，比如，噢，我正准备吃东西，但我吃完后会出去。你想陪我一起吃吗，然后我们可以一起出去？
And when we went outside to the garden, I would just be in my body. I wouldn't feel my flesh. And if my neighbor came over I would wave and chat, and not feel fake or terrified. There would just be an ease. And if something did rise up, some spikiness, some fear, some urge to reach for food or to reject it, I'd be able to handle it. And if, despite my best efforts, I submitted to it, I'd be able to tolerate the disappointment.
当我们去外面花园时，我会身心合一。我不会感到我的肉体。如果邻居过来，我会挥手聊天，而不感到虚伪或恐惧。那会是一种自在。如果有什么东西升起，一些尖锐感、一些恐惧、一些想要伸手拿食物或拒绝食物的冲动，我能够处理它。而且如果尽管我尽了最大努力，还是屈服了，我也能容忍那种失望。
I don't know if that would feel like recovery to me. I don't think I can know until I get there. But I think it would feel like sturdiness.
我不知道那对我来说是否感觉像康复。我不认为在达到那个状态之前我能知道。但我认为那会感觉像“坚固”。
Susan Burton, she's an editor on our program. Her memoir about her eating disorder is called Empty.
Susan Burton，她是我们的项目编辑。她关于饮食失调的回忆录名为《空虚》。
Coming up, people in bars ask a question that Dr. Fauci has not weighed in on yet-- which COVID vaccine is the most likely to get somebody to make out with you? That's in a minute on Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，酒吧里的人们提出了一个福奇医生尚未表态的问题——哪种新冠疫苗最有可能让人和你接吻？请在我们的节目继续进行时，收听芝加哥公共广播电台的报道，稍后揭晓。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "The Thing I'm Getting Over," stories of people who are in the middle of changing their lives, figuring out the puzzle of exactly how they're going to get from where they were to where they're heading. We have arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, Shot Girl Summer in the City.
这里是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。今天的节目，“我正在克服的事情”，讲述了人们在改变生活、弄清楚如何从过去走向未来的拼图中不断前行的故事。我们来到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，城市里的 shots girl 夏天。
So this past spring when more and more people started getting their COVID vaccines, this phrase kept popping up when people talked about the country getting back on its feet.
今年春天，当越来越多的人开始接种新冠疫苗时，这个短语在人们谈论国家恢复元气时不断出现。
What does this mean, the hot vax summer?
这是什么意思，火热疫苗夏天？
America is vaxed and waxed. Hot girl summer is now shot girl summer.
美国已经接种了疫苗并脱毛了。热门女孩夏天现在变成了 Shots girl 夏天。
Hot vax summer in the city.
城市里的火热疫苗夏天。
Shot girl summer-- it's the idea that, this summer, people who got the shots and have all this pent-up energy from over a year of isolation will be out there hooking up like never before. It all got started as a Twitter joke and ended up as something they were actually covering on local news. And I think it got all this attention because it is a very understandable way to measure how far the country has come in its recovery from COVID. But you know, what's reality here? What is shot girl summer like, really, for the people living it?
Shots girl 夏天——这个想法是，这个夏天，那些打了疫苗、从长达一年的隔离中积压了所有能量的人，将像以前从未有过那样去外面约会。这一切最初只是一个Twitter笑话，最后变成了他们实际上在当地新闻中报道的东西。我认为它受到如此关注，是因为这是衡量一个国家在疫情康复中走多远的一种非常可以理解的方式。但是你知道，这里的现实是什么？对生活在其中的人们来说，Shots girl 夏天真正是什么样的？
Elna Baker looked into that. Quick warning, if you're listening with kids-- there's nothing explicit in this story at all, but it does acknowledge that sex exists and is a thing between adults. Here's Elna.
Elna Baker进行了调查。简单警告，如果你和孩子一起听——故事里没有任何露骨的东西，但它确实承认性是存在的，并且是成年人之间的事情。下面请听Elna的报道。
I've heard this summer compared to the Roaring '20s or the '60s Summer of Love. I've read articles about people making out in the streets. I've seen the viral picture of a condom shelf at Walgreens in New York City that is so empty it looks like it's been raided. And I've heard waxing salons were booming with lots of people prepping to be naked in front of one another for the first time in 15 months. So I decided to stop by a salon, Sugaring New York City. I talked to a waxer named Parminder, who said, yeah, this is true.
我听过有人把这个夏天比作“咆哮的20年代”或“60年代爱之夏”。我读过关于人们在街上接吻的文章。我看到了纽约沃尔格林药店避孕套货架的病毒式照片，那个货架空得看起来像是被洗劫过一样。我还听说脱毛沙龙生意兴隆，有很多人在为15个月来第一次在彼此面前赤裸做准备。所以我决定去一家沙龙看看，Sugaring New York City。我和一位名叫Parminder的脱毛师聊了聊，她说，是的，这是真的。
Oh, yeah, definitely. Sometimes it's so busy that you don't even get a break to even have a snack in between. You're running in and out, clients like in and out throughout the room. And it's good because the day goes by faster.
噢，是的，绝对是。有时候忙到中间连吃零食的休息时间都没有。你跑进跑出，顾客在房间里进进出出。这很好，因为时间过得更快。
But that's one of the things I witnessed in the lobby, the urgency. This woman was trying to make an appointment, and she was like, no, I have to. I have to. You guys are like-- it's like the doors are being knocked down right now. Why? Why is the urgency so big right now?
但我在大厅里目睹的事情之一就是这种紧迫感。这个女人试图预约，她说，不，我必须。我必须。你们是……就像门现在正被撞开一样。为什么？为什么现在的紧迫感这么大？
Hookups, late, last-minute hookups.
约炮，深夜，最后一分钟的约炮。
And the hype is specifically about sex this summer, right?
而且这个炒作专门是关于今年夏天的性，对吧？
Exactly.
没错。
This is another waxer I spoke to, Corina.
这是我采访的另一位脱毛师，Corina。
Especially with the Brazilians, yeah. I've had numerous people say, I'm getting this Brazilian for a shot girl summer.
特别是做巴西式脱毛，是的。我有很多客人说，我做这个巴西式脱毛是为了迎接 Shots girl 夏天。
The staff at a cafe and bar on the Bowery called Short Stories confirmed the trend with the most television-ready quotes I've ever heard. Are people acting bolder and hornier this summer?
一家名为Short Stories的Bowery咖啡馆和酒吧的员工证实了这个趋势，他们的话是我听过最适合上电视的语录。今年夏天人们的行为更大胆、更饥渴了吗？
On a level that we thought not possible since the inception of the internet, since the newspaper and the printing press went into effect.
达到了我们认为自互联网诞生、自报纸和印刷机投入使用以来不可能达到的程度。
That's Tom, the late night manager.
那是Tom，夜班经理。
It's been unprecedented, to say the very least.
这至少可以说是史无前例的。
I asked him, what's his proof?
我问他，你的证据是什么？
The amount of bleach that we use in the bathroom is probably at an astronomically all-time high. I'm waiting to restock the bathroom, make sure everything's OK. And it's kind of like, OK, well, there's a couple of people coming out all at the same time, and belts aren't on, which is interesting because our lost and found is currently filled with pants. I don't know-- I've never seen this happen. I've got skirts. I've got shorts.
我们在洗手间使用的漂白剂数量可能处于天文数字般的历史最高点。我等着补充洗手间用品，确保一切正常。然后就有点像，好吧，有几个人同时出来，而且没系腰带，这很有趣，因为我们的失物招领处目前装满了裤子。我不知道——我从没见过这种情况。我有裙子。我有短裤。
Is this is true?
这是真的吗？
This is true. When was the last time you went somewhere and lost your pants?
这是真的。你上次去哪里弄丢裤子是什么时候？
For the record, six years ago, my friend Ayesha's birthday.
说实话，六年前，我朋友Ayesha的生日。
Joey, the beverage director, has been watching people try to get back in the game. One of the things she notices is how quickly people cut to the chase. The most common pickup line, which vaccine do you have?
饮料主管Joey一直在观察人们试图重回游戏状态。她注意到的事情之一是人们切入正题的速度有多快。最常见的搭讪词是，你打的是哪种疫苗？
It's the new "Do you come here often?" Yeah. So Pfizer, Moderna, you know? It's a club. It's a club. It's incredible.
这是新的“你常来这吗？”是的。所以辉瑞，莫德纳，你知道吗？这是一个俱乐部。这是一个俱乐部。这太不可思议了。
God, that's so boring. That's such a boring opener.
天呐，这太无聊了。这是一个多么无聊的开场白。
It's completely vapid, it's so boring, and it does the trick.
它完全乏味，非常无聊，而且还挺管用。
People at the bars did seem to have a lot of vaccine brand loyalty. One woman told me she had Moderna, which she liked best because when you say "I'm Moderna," it sounds like you're saying "I'm a modern woman."
酒吧里的人似乎对疫苗品牌有很多忠诚度。一位女士告诉我她打了莫德纳，她最喜欢它，因为当你大声说“我是莫德纳”时，听起来就像在说“我是现代女性”。
What are your shots?
你打的是什么针？
I am a Pfizer girl.
我是辉瑞女孩。
Moderna.
莫德纳。
Pfizer.
辉瑞。
Johnson & Johnson.
强生。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
One and done.
一针搞定。
I spent a couple nights outside of bars talking to dozens of people, looking for evidence that hookups are on the rise, asking for stories. And I have breaking news for everyone-- shot girl summer is a sham. It's one of the oldest lies in the book, straight out of a high school locker room-- lots of people talking about having sex, but no actual sex.
我在酒吧外度过了几个晚上，和几十个人交谈，寻找约炮在增加的证据，询问他们的故事。我要告诉大家一个突发新闻——Shots girl 夏天是一个骗局。这是书里最古老的谎言之一，直接出自高中更衣室——很多人在谈论性，但并没有实际的性行为。
Everyone's been horny for months. Now is the time everyone's unleashing. If you're not getting laid, something's been majorly wrong.
每个人都已经饥渴了好几个月了。现在是每个人释放的时候。如果你没有发生性关系，那肯定是哪里出了大问题。
Are you getting laid?
你有发生性关系吗？
I have a boyfriend, so yeah.
我有男朋友，所以是的。
Friends, that's not a thing. Having sex in a long-term partnership is not the post-pandemic bacchanalian free for all we've all been hearing about.
朋友们，那不算。在长期伴侣关系中发生性关系，并不是我们一直听说的那种大流行后的狂欢聚会。
Are you having lots of hookups this summer?
你这个夏天有很多约炮吗？
Not really, no.
没怎么有，没有。
Really?
真的吗？
No. Maybe people are [BLEEP] more than they were, but--
没有。也许人们比以前[词汇消音]更多了，但是……
But you're not?
但你没有？
But I'm not, no.
但我没有，没。
One night, a friend and I were out at a hookah bar, talking about how none of the single people we know are hooking up during shot girl summer. We named names. It was a long list. We turned to the table next to us, a bunch of attractive 20-somethings dressed for a night out, and I explained I have this theory that everyone is saying we're all having casual sex right now, but nobody actually is. Is this true?
有一天晚上，我和一个朋友在水烟吧，谈论我们认识的单身人士中没有任何人在“Shots girl 夏天”约炮。我们列举了名字。那是一个很长的名单。我们转向隔壁桌，一群打扮好准备出去玩、很有吸引力的20多岁年轻人，我解释说我有一个理论，每个人都在说我们现在都在进行休闲性行为，但实际上没有人这么做。这是真的吗？
They told me no, I was dead wrong. This summer is wild. This is the summer to be single in New York. They've been going crazy.
他们告诉我不，我大错特错了。这个夏天非常狂野。这是在纽约单身的夏天。他们一直玩得很疯。
And I was like, oh, OK. So you guys are having sex? One by one they each said no, no, no. I started recording.
于是我说，噢，好的。所以你们在发生性关系？他们一个接一个都说没有，没有，没有。我开始录音了。
--used to be before.
……以前是那样的。
Yeah, but I feel like we just cracked some case where everyone is saying everyone is [BLEEP]. And what we've discovered is no one is [BLEEP].
是的，但我觉得我们刚刚破获了一个案件，每个人都在说每个人都在[词汇消音]。而我们发现的是没有人[词汇消音]。
I think that's the intention of the people. Everybody wants to [BLEEP]. They just forgot how to do it and how to start a conversation with a stranger. Going to feel I'm weird or think I'm weird, or whatever. But are we going to break that ice? They'd be like, yeah, who cares?
我认为那是人们的初衷。每个人都想[词汇消音]。他们只是忘记了怎么做，也忘记了怎么和陌生人开始对话。担心我会觉得我很奇怪，或者认为我很奇怪，或者别的什么。但我们要打破僵局吗？他们会说，是的，谁在乎呢？
So in theory--
所以在理论上……
In theory, that's the plan. And practically, we have to figure it out.
在理论上，这是计划。但在实际中，我们必须弄清楚。
Of all my friends, if anyone was having a shot girl summer, as in hooking up, there's one that had to be. Her name is Mads. She's 25. She goes out almost every night, travels in a pack of single girls. I asked her if this is the summer of hookups for her or any of her friends.
在我所有的朋友中，如果有人在过 Shots girl 夏天，比如约炮，有一个肯定在过。她叫Mads。她25岁。她几乎每天晚上都出去，混迹于单身女孩群中。我问她这是不是她或她任何朋友的约炮夏天。
We're going out together. We're trying to have sex. We're trying to have a good time. But none of us are finding anything.
我们一起出去。我们试图发生性关系。我们试图玩得开心。但我们谁也没找到任何进展。
Because all that bartenders-- I talk to bartenders. I talk to people who work in waxing salons. I talk to people doing all the prep work to get people sex ready or whatever.
因为所有的酒保——我问过酒保。我问过在脱毛沙龙工作的人。我问过做所有准备工作让人们做好性准备的人。
And they're all like, yeah, people are like-- they're boning. It's wild. But then as far as they know, that's what people are doing, because people leave the bar together. But in reality, what you're seeing is--
他们都说，是的，人们……他们在乱搞。太狂野了。但就他们所知，那是人们在做的事情，因为人们一起离开酒吧。但在现实中，你所看到的是……
-- no bone zone, no bone town USA.
……没有乱搞区，没有“乱搞镇”美国。
So if no one's having sex, what is even just-- help me understand the transaction. Like, what happens when you meet someone? What goes down?
所以如果没人发生性关系，那这个交易到底是什么？比如，当你遇见某人时发生了什么？发生了什么？
There is back and forth banter, teasing. Then you-- I don't know-- sometimes get drunk and then just start talking about all the things you want to do to one another. You get in a cab. You go back to their apartment. And then you're alone with them, and you just want to hug.
会有来回的打趣，调情。然后你……我不知道……有时候喝醉了，然后就开始谈论你们想对彼此做的所有事情。你上出租车。你回到他们的公寓。然后你和他们单独在一起，你只想拥抱。
And that's on both sides?
这是双方的吗？
Yeah. Yeah. In fact, I tried to sleep with a few people recently. And it was them. They were not interested. It didn't work. And they were just like, sorry. I don't know why.
是的。是的。事实上，我最近尝试和几个人睡。但对方……他们不感兴趣。没成功。他们只是说，抱歉。我不知道为什么。
One of them was like, can I just hold you? And the other one was like, can I just like take a shower with you, and we can talk? It's like people really looking for things that make them feel comfortable after this year.
其中一个说，我可以只是抱抱你吗？另一个说，我可以和你一起洗个澡，我们可以聊聊吗？就像人们在经历这一年后，真的在寻找能让他们感到舒适的东西。
Yeah, we're all flinging ourselves back out into the whirlwind of dating in the city, and we're not equipped at all.
是的，我们都把自己重新扔回了城市约会的漩涡中，而我们根本没有准备好。
Why?
为什么？
This last year, I know people who've died from COVID. I know people who are really sick. I lost my job. I went through a breakup. I lost my home and had to move to a new city to move in with my family. And now I tried to date normally the way that I used to, but I can't. I feel more raw and honest with myself and with others, but I think that doesn't really result in sexy times.
去年一年，我认识的人里有人死于新冠。我认识的人里有人病得很重。我失业了。我经历了一次分手。我失去了家，不得不搬到一个新城市去和家人住在一起。现在我尝试像过去那样正常约会，但我做不到。我觉得自己对自己和他人更加赤诚和诚实，但我认为这并没有带来性快感。
This tracks with my experience. Recently, I went out with this guy whose profile said, I'm just coming out of a long-term monogamous relationship and not looking to get back into one. I interpreted this as code for hookups only.
这与我的经历相符。最近，我和一个男生出去约会，他的个人资料上写着：我刚结束一段长期的单身关系，不打算再开始一段。我把这解读为约炮的暗号。
But then when we went out, he talked to me for three hours about all the inner reflection the pandemic had led to and how he couldn't be with someone until he sorted out his demons. I, in turn, told him how sick I'd gotten, how it took me a full three months to recover. It was sweet, but not as advertised.
但当我们出去时，他和我聊了三个小时关于大流行带来的内心反思，以及他在理清自己的魔鬼之前怎么不能和别人在一起。反过来，我告诉了他我病得有多重，我花了整整三个月才康复。这很甜蜜，但并不是他资料里写的那样。
I've been out with five other guys since. It starts hot and ends feeling like I've been to a support group. It's confusing. Mads agrees.
从那以后我又和另外五个男生出去过。开始很火热，结束时感觉像参加了支持小组。这很令人困惑。Mads也同意。
You're in the mood, and then you're not, all of a sudden. It's weird. I don't know. I can't put my finger on what it is, really.
你很有兴致，然后突然间就没有了。这很奇怪。我不知道。我真的说不清是什么原因。
I definitely felt like there is a thing inside of me that's-- yeah, there's a sadness inside of me that will be fine. I'm good at hiding it. I'm good at not addressing it. But then when I'm alone with someone in this intimate setting, it flares up inside of me, and something flares up inside of them too.
我绝对感觉到我内心有一种东西是——是的，我内心有一种会好起来的悲伤。我很擅长隐藏它。我很擅长不解决它。但当我和某人在这种亲密的环境中单独相处时，它在我内心爆发，也让他们内心的东西爆发了。
I used to worry that the things that I had been through, my traumas and sadnesses, ruined me for other people, just people who wanted to have fun or were cool and nice. In a way, it's kind of lovely to feel like, oh, I see this in everyone now.
我曾经担心我所经历的事情、我的创伤和悲伤会毁了我，让别人无法接受，只是那些想玩得开心或者很酷很友善的人。在某种程度上，感觉像是，噢，我现在在每个人身上都能看到这一点，这种感觉挺可爱的。
I thought it would be a sign of recovery if people were moving on, cutting loose, leaving the past year behind. But instead, it seemed like they felt very aware of what they've been through, what everyone is feeling. That decision to not look away, to embrace the sadness, that's a sign of recovery too.
我以为如果人们继续前进、打破束缚、把过去的一年抛在脑后，会是康复的迹象。但相反，看起来他们对自己的经历以及每个人的感受感到非常清醒。那种不移开视线、拥抱悲伤的决定，那也是康复的迹象。
Elna Baker is a producer on our show.
Elna Baker是我们节目的制作人。
Today's program was produced by Lilly Sullivan and Susan Burton. The people who put together today's show include Bim Adewunmi, Elna Baker, Sean Cole, Noor Gill, Damien Graef, Chana Jaffe-Walt, Beth Lake, Mary Marge Locker, Tobin Low, Miki Meek, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Ari Saperstein, Alissa Shipp, Jessica Suriano, Christopher Swetala, Chloee Weiner, and Diane Wu. Managing editor, Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks today to Anna Barone-Cone, Andrea LaMarre, and Ashwin Deshmukh.
今天的节目由Lilly Sullivan和Susan Burton制作。制作今天节目的成员包括Bim Adewunmi、Elna Baker、Sean Cole、Noor Gill、Damien Graef、Chana Jaffe-Walt、Beth Lake、Mary Marge Locker、Tobin Low、Miki Meek、Stowe Nelson、Katherine Rae Mondo、Nadia Reiman、Ari Saperstein、Alissa Shipp、Jessica Suriano、Christopher Swetala、Chloee Weiner和Diane Wu。执行编辑Sarah Abdurrahman。我们的高级编辑是David Kestenbaum。我们的执行编辑是Emanuele Berry。特别感谢Anna Barone-Cone、Andrea LaMarre和Ashwin Deshmukh。
If you want to see the videos that Chase Friedman made of kicking his friend in the nethers, and the Rocky steps, and giving the finger, and other stuff, they're at his TikTok account. His handle there is @chasegetsbetter, all one word, or on Instagram, he is @chaseunfiltered. Our website, thisamericanlife.org, you can stream our archive of over 700 episodes for absolutely free. Also, there's videos and lists of favorite shows for your summer car trip listening and tons of other stuff there too. Again, thisamericanlife.org.
如果你想看Chase Friedman制作的踢他朋友下体的视频、洛奇台阶视频、竖中指视频以及其他内容，它们在他的TikTok账号上。他的账号名是@chasegetsbetter，全部拼在一起，或者在Instagram上，他是@chaseunfiltered。我们的网站thisamericanlife.org，你可以免费在线收听我们700多集的档案。此外，还有视频和最受欢迎节目的列表，适合你的夏季自驾游收听，网站上还有很多其他内容。再次申明，thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He is the worst person to tell a joke to. Knock knock. Who's there?
《美国生活》由公共广播交流中心（PRX）分发给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人Torey Malatia先生。他是讲笑话时最糟糕的对象。敲敲门。谁在那里？
[LAUGHS] Sorry. What was the first one?
[笑] 抱歉。第一个是什么？
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Ira Glass，下周将带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。